I got this problem here from the 2003
ami exam that stands for the American
Invitational mathematics exam and this
was actually the first problem in the
exam the product n of three positive
integers is 6 times their sum and one of
the integers is the sum of the other to
find the sum of all possible values of n
so we have to deal with three positive
integers so we have three positive
integers right over here so let's just
think about three positive integers
let's call them a B and C they're all
positive they're all integers the
product n of these three these three
positive integers so a times B times C
is equal to n is 6 times their sum this
is equal to 6 times the sum let me do
this in another color
so this is their product so the product
n of three positive integers is 6 times
is 6 times their sum so this is equal to
6 times the sum of those integers a plus
B plus C and one of the integers is the
sum of the other two one one of the
integers is the sum of the other two
well let's just pick C to be the sum of
a and B we could do it doesn't matter
these are just names and we haven't said
one of them is larger or less than the
other one so let's just say that a plus
B is equal to C the one of the integers
is the sum of the other two C is the sum
of a plus B find the sum of all possible
values of n so let's just try to do a
little bit of manipulation of the
information we have here and maybe we
can get some relationship or some
constraints on our numbers and then we
can kind of go through all of the
possibilities so let's see we know that
a plus B is equal to C so we can replace
C we can replace C everywhere with a
plus B so this expression right over
here becomes a B which is just a times B
times C but instead of C I'm going to
write an A plus B over here
a plus B and then that is equal to six
times that is equal to six times a plus
B a plus B plus C and so once again I'll
replace the C with an A plus B and then
what does this simplify to
so on the right hand side we have six
times a plus B plus a plus B this is the
same thing as six times 2a plus 2b 2a
plus 2b just added the A's and the B's
and we can factor out a 2 this is the
same thing as if you take out a 2 6
times 2 is 12 times a plus B the left
hand side right over here is still is
still a times B or a B times a plus B so
a B times a plus B has got to be equal
to 12 times a plus B so this is pretty
interesting here we can divide both
sides by a plus B we know that a plus B
won't be equal to cannot be equal to
zero since all of these numbers have to
be positive numbers so if we divide both
sides and the reason why I say that is
if it was zero dividing by zero would
give you an undefined answer so if we
divide both sides by a plus B we get a
times B is equal to 12 so all the
constraints that they gave us boiled
down to this right over here the product
of a and B is equal to 12 and there's
only there's only so many numbers so
many positive integers where you take
the product you get 12 let's try them
out let's try them out so let me write
some columns here let's say a b c and
then we care we care about their product
we care about the products so i'll write
that over here so a b c so if a is 1 if
a is 1 B is going to be 12 C is the sum
of those two so C is going to be 13 12
one times 12 times 13 12 times 12 is 144
plus another 12 is going to be 156 and
just out of just for fun you can verify
that this is going to be equal to 6
times there
some there some is 26 26 times six is
156 so this one definitely worked it
definitely worked for the constraints as
it should because we boil down those
constraints to a times B need to be
equal to 12 so let's try another one
two times six their sum is eight and
then if I were to take the product of
all of these you get 2 times 6 is 12
times 8 is 96 96 then we could try 3 & 4
3 plus 4 is 7 3 times 4 is 3 times 4 is
12 times 7 actually I should have known
but a times B is always 12 so we just
have to multiply 12 times this last
column 12 times 7 is 84 12 times 7 is 84
and there aren't any others you can't go
you definitely can't go above 12 because
then you would have to deal with non
integers you'd have to deal with
fractions you can't do the negative
versions of these because they all have
to be positive integers so that's it
those are all of the possible positive
integers where you take their products
you get you get 12 we've essentially
just factored 12 so they want to they
want us to find the sum of all possible
values of n well these are all the
possible values of N and theirs are the
product of those integers so let's just
take let's just take the sum 6 plus 6 is
12 plus 4 is 16 1 plus 5 is 6 plus 9 is
15 plus 8 is 23 2 plus 1 is 3 so our
answer is 336